ORAL ARGUMENTS WILL BE HELD
SOMETIME NEXT YEAR.
PRESIDENT-ELECT JOE BIDEN IS
CALLING THE NOVEMBER JOBS REPORT
"DYER" IN SIZE CONGRESS AND
PRESIDENT TRUMP MUST PROVIDE
IMMEDIATE RELIEF FOR FAMILIES
AND BUSINESSES.
IF THE BIDEN SAYS THAT WHATEVER
COMES, IT’S JUST A DOWN PAYMENT.
A CORRESPONDENT PETER DOOCY
REPORTING FROM WILMINGTON,
DELAWARE, TONIGHT.
>> PRESIDENT-ELECT KNOW HE WILL
INHERENT IN INTO A ECONOMY
AFFECTED BY THE PANDEMIC.
>> FOLKS OUT THERE AND LOOKING
FOR HANDOUTS.
THEY JUST NEED HELP.
>> HE’S PLEASED BIPARTISAN GROUP
OF SENATORS REACHING ACROSS THE
AISLE.
MORE THAN $900 BILLION STIMULUS
PROPOSAL.
>> IF WE ACT NOW, NOW, I MEAN
NOW.
WE CAN BEGIN TO REGAIN MOMENTUM.
>> HE WON’T REVEAL WHAT HE’S
BEEN TELLING ELECTED OFFICIALS.
>> WELL, TO BE KIND OF STUPID OF
ME TO TELL YOU WHAT I DID, IS
ANNETTE?
IT’S HARD TO DO IT AGAIN.
[LAUGHS]
>> TRANSITION OFFICIALS SAY MANY
CABINET ANNOUNCEMENTS ARE COMING
SOON.
>> COFFEE OR SPINACH WHATEVER
KEEPS YOU GOING, YOU WILL BE
BUSY BETWEEN NOW AND CHRISTMAS.
>> BUSY AT THE HOUSE OVERSIGHT
COMMITTEE AND THE REPUBLICANS
WANT TO KNOW WHY CALIFORNIA
SECRETARY OF STATE COULD BE
APPOINTED TO TAKING, HERE IS HIS
SEAT SOON.
MAKING VOTER CONTACT.
>> HE IS THE FACT THAT GOVERNOR
GOVERNOR NEWSOM EXCEPTS TO HAVE
REPLACED HARRIS, HE WILL GO
BEFORE THE COMMITTEE ETHICS ETHI
>> THE TRANSITION TEAM IS
GETTING UP TO SPEED ON OPERATION
WARP SPEED.
>> THERE IS NO DETAILED PLAN
THAT WE’VE SEEN AS TO HOW YOU
GET THE VACCINE OUT OF A
CONTAINER.
INTO AN INJECTION SYRINGE INTO
SOMEBODY’S ARM.
>> FOX NEWS ASK THE
PRESIDENT-ELECT WHAT HAPPENS
NEXT.
>> NO, SHOULD NOT BE MANDATORY.
I WILL NOT DEMAND IT WILL BE
MANDATORY BUT I’LL DO EVERYTHING
IN MY POWER LIKE I DON’T THINK
MASKS HAVE TO BE MADE MANDATORY
NATIONWIDE.
>> BIDEN WOULD NOT COMMIT TO
PICKING A PERSON OF COLOR AS HIS
SECRETARY OF DEFENSE OR
ATTORNEY GENERAL.
HIS CABINET WILL BE THE MOST
DIVERSE EVER AND HE IS SHRUGGING
OFF COMPLAINTS ABOUT THE LACK OF
DIVERSITY SO FAR FROM CIVIL
RIGHTS GROUPS SAYING THAT THOSE
GROUPS JOB TO PUSH LEADERS FOR
MORE DIVERSITY.
JOHN.
>> John: HE GAVE UP ON HIS